do you think that women have an
expiration date on dating
like do you think there's any urgency to
like find a husband sooner rather than
later
um I I think like I wouldn't like to say
yes but I think so I think yeah even you
guys you're gonna have more options now
than well they say that men get better
with age and um at some point too but
yeah but they say that that's it you
know men are allowed to be a silver fox
whereas women have to get BOTOX and dye
their hair and again you've got like the
whole biological like boy it's just like
we get we get that attention immediately
so like I remember being like 15 16 and
I was like why is everyone paying
attention to me now you know braces came
off and [ __ ] like
and but like men don't have that like
they're they're like invisible to the
world so it's like a trade-off yeah so
so right now you there's there are
things you've admitted on this show that
you get special favors and stuff because
you're a young 100 I am yeah right but
men don't get that for the first half of
their lives so like the people will cry
and say it's like not fair but it's like
the most fair thing ever and it's a very
small percentage of men that actually
become Silver Fox it's not the majority
most men don't even get half that level
of advantage that most young attractive
women have and I think well then as a
man gets older it then comes to
um what you can provide an older man
you're gonna maybe assume you've got
more finances you've got more XYZ I
don't know I think men I actually don't
know I find women a lot more attractive
than men like categorically women are a
lot more attractive than me today over
here oh yes yeah no even though men are
a lot more attractive than men
um but it's as a man gets older you do
just assume like you're probably going
to be more ahead in your career you're
probably going to be so that yourself is
more attractive but it's oh yeah I think
that like man I don't know I'm not
really attracted to 50 year olds like I
think I'm gonna be like I'm not
physically attracted to them I mean Mark
Ruffalo I would call him daddy any day
of the week what's what's what's the
oldest you would actually consider for a
husband
uh 15 20.
years old no years older no it's like
you no no no no like I'm like I'm 25 so
maybe 45. so you would consider a 40
year old guy seriously for marriage and
so yeah if you're no kids sure most of
them most of them probably have children
but like if you look good no kids sign
me up how about you all right it would
really depend because I know some like
men who are post 50 who are really
they're running like Iron Man's
triathlons so so if they were like they
want to marry you start a life with you
you'd be open to that
do you know what I'm gonna be real
honest I I would I would be a gold
digger if there is an 80 year old man on
his deathbed who is like
I I would do it I would do it for that
easy life there's there's no limit age
limit for you
I mean realistically yeah there is like
that's me just like
kind of like being realistically I'm
like
oh [ __ ] I don't know because oh there's
a lot of [ __ ] to go in there like even
like Health even like how open are they
to travel how committed are they to
their job how like no all those things
are there I'm just saying the age what's
the age limit
I like I'm trying to think the perfect
age I prefer guys my age but usually I
think like they're usually more like
looking for something casual yeah so
that's what I like guys in their mid-30s
not because I'm more attracted to them
but just because like they're kind of in
this like I don't know they're not in
like the Casual yeah you know it's weird
like I
can get butchered out here if I say this
um I feel like for a mental thing I
prefer women who are older to actually
talk to on a on a on a standard basis
I'd say is generalization
but then if it's just casual fun then to
be honest it's kind of if she's
attractive I have a hot take I think
girls peek at like 18 at the time yeah
yeah Rose tomasi says like 22-23 I think
personally for me I would I would say
and we're talking General I would say 24
25 because that's when I say she's still
like if she was hot at 22 she's not
gonna not be hot at 24. do you know what
I mean but she's probably more mature
and I value that I think that 18 year
olds look the best because most girls no
most girls don't gain weight in college
I know but they just look like most
girls get like beer bellies and call it
I just think I just think like because
I'm I'm at that age where girls who hit
on me are around that age yeah and I
find it weird because they just look
like children to me yeah whereas I'm
like now I wanna I want a woman yeah a
young woman but I want a woman you know
what I mean like I feel like I don't
know that's why that's why it's like
yeah I just yeah I couldn't I couldn't
like I couldn't get a girl who looked
incredibly young looking I'd feel weird
I know some guys love that [ __ ] but
that's I don't know 18 year olds
nowadays look like they're 25. oh
okay I'm like I see I'm like what the I
don't know
but yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't go lower
than 23 though he wouldn't go lower than
23. yeah
I remember the day that old guys got hot
it was really weird it was like I didn't
see guys I did when I was 21 or 22. I
was going on dates with a guy that was
30 and I just couldn't get past it I was
like I can't he's so old
I remember like thinking like
oh he's 30 like that's so old and but
now I remember being like 24 I mean like
are 40 year olds attract our dad's hot
yes oh my God it was a weird it was so
weird it didn't happen until like 24 23
maybe I was like oh this is strange this
is strange I have a question for both of
you is there a diff well
what would you say is your dating age
range but then you're sleeping casual
sexual age range so for me I would
personally happily sleep with someone
who was like 21 but I wouldn't date
someone who was 21. I wouldn't like
yeah I kind of I look for it all just
like it's the same to me okay wait I
don't know serious okay no no seriously
like yeah like oh like between casual
and serious uh I'd say casual
anywhere between
23 to like
I mean I've dated a woman in her late
40s before so I'd say like 23 to like 48
if we're talking series I need to see
what she looks like I need
she's hot
if I wasn't going to be serious about
someone I definitely the younger they
are I'm like it doesn't matter
let me see okay
I'm Gonna Keep the mic this way and I'm
just gonna hope that you why you still
got it for kids sake I'm gonna oh is
that a why you still got it well you
still got it excuse me
is that is that is that a thing don't
guys keep like albums of all the nudes
they have well it might if I end things
with a guy I have to I say to them I'm
like respectfully I would like you to
delete anything I've sent you but
[Music]
[Applause]
or if they get a girl that's like I need
you to delete this but I'm fully aware
that if I ever send something I'm fully
aware I'm fully aware that if I send
something to someone that I'm and I
don't advocate for it at all but I'm
aware that one they're probably gonna
show some of their male friends I know
that I know that's happened to me before
that they'll be like this is a girl I'm
sleeping with this the Girl I'm dating
I'm well aware that if I send something
that's it uh it's it goes back to
consequences if I send a nude photo or a
promiscuous photo I am well aware that
it probably will not just stay in his
phone or with him and it probably will
not end when I wanted to comment on this
on what I'm the album
listen ladies
if you send a guy a nude photo it is on
his phone forever that's all I'm gonna
say and I say this I say this in my
videos you guys you guys show each other
their girlfriends nudes